hey this is preshtalwalker
a rectangle is divided into four
rectangles with the following areas
the yellow rectangle has an area of 16
the blue rectangle has an area of 13 and
the green rectangle has an area of 39
what is the area of the orange rectangle
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
you could solve this problem by setting
up variables and then eventually solving
for the area of the unknown rectangle
but there is a geometric principle that
will make the problem a lot easier
first notice that the green and the blue
rectangle share the same height
this means we can figure out the width
of the green rectangle relative to the
width of the blue rectangle
because the area of the green rectangle
is three times the area of the blue
rectangle
this means the blue rectangle fits
exactly three times into the green
rectangle
the green rectangle has the width that
is three times the blue rectangle
this means the orange rectangle has a
width that is three times that of the
yellow rectangle
so the yellow rectangle will fit exactly
three times into the orange rectangle
therefore the area of the orange
rectangle will be 3 times that of 16
which is 48.
did you figure this out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description